welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and this video we're going to be
breaking down the empire strikes batch
episode a is now out worldwide and we're
officially halfway through the first
season
for real this time now throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
everything you need to know about the
show
it's easter eggs and our theories on
what's coming around the corner
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you turn off now
good soldiers follow orders and they
like and subscribe
as they know to stay loyal to heavy
spoilers or else
now without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the bad
batch
okay so in the last episode it was
revealed that rex was the contact of the
martez sisters
and he rocked up to sid's bar to meet
with the batch
what's sid's favorite drink cider
hey having that now after learning that
the clones all still had their chips
he realized that they could turn to the
dark side at any second
rex is someone who in the clone wars had
to bury his brothers
after they ended up falling victim to
the empirical brainwashing
thus the group set out to bracka a
planet that we got to play on in star
wars fall in order
here we were introduced to carl kestus a
jedi padawan that managed to survive
order 66.
the game was about him very much being
exposed and the repercussions of it as
he tried to become a jedi
he worked for the scrapper guild who we
saw at the end of the episode
spying on the batch now amongst the old
ships rex found a medical bay
but rekka ended up going evil just like
someone who makes
50 videos a week about how kathleen
kennedy has been fired
because they didn't like the last jedi
the match managed to stop him
and remove his chip and one by one they
had them taken out
leaving scars similar to the one that
rex has on his head
the episode ended with rex leaving and
we do know from rebels that he ended up
retiring with a character named gregor
i've always wondered if that's a nod to
you and mcgregor but never mind now we
pick up with the empire closing in
and they're rushing to the area like
anakin would have if he'd been told
there's a second hand sale
at the darth maul get it because he got
a second hand
and darth maul like maul now episode 8
is titled reunion
and it feels like so long since we've
last seen cross hair that i was actually
happy to see him back
even if he's now a brainwashed
psychopath worst things have happened at
my high school ones to
be fair now we pick up on camino and
watch as admiral rampart instructs the
prime minister that he has to be
informed of any and all dealings on the
planet
this shows that the empire are now truly
running the show and they went from
customers to the currents that
think they run the business and that
everything should cater to them
turns out the scrapper guild signal has
made its way to crosshair
and though lamazoo wants them brought in
alive because the clones are going to be
decommissioned
rampart wants them tomorrow needed now
come back to braca
and i forgot to point out last week that
amongst the junkyard you can make out a
hammerhead corvette
if you cast your mind back to rogue one
then you'll remember that this was used
to push a star destroyer
and it's one of the best new ships in
star wars lore
we catch rekka teaching omega some
valuable life lessons
like how to dismantle a thermal
explosive turns out there's tons of them
buried in the scrapyard
and if you trigger one then you need to
know how to take it apart
gee i wonder if that might come up in
the future now omega accidentally
triggers it
but it turns out that wrecker was just
using a smoke version
nice that he's gone from almost
murdering her last week and now just
pretending to do it
now we see this scrapper guild still
stalking them but the batch quickly
become aware that they've been spied
upon
and they end up taking them down it was
good to see more of the helmet designs
that we witnessed in fallen order
and i would have loved it if cal had
shown up but he was only a kid at the
time
so it probably took him a while to reach
the planet now what do you call it when
a delivery driver drops your parcel
you fall in order it's the way i tell
them now one of the guild takes a tippy
tumble over the cliff
it was kind of good that we didn't get a
wilhelm scream however it's not all bad
news
and the batch realized that because the
dying noga has kept the scrappers away
that the ship they're on hasn't been
ransacked in case you missed our last
video
dying ogres tend to live in sewage
systems on ships
and these giant tentacle monsters were
used in both the death star trash
compactor
and as a boss in shadows of the empire
this also explains why the medical bay
was still in working order
as that would have been taken apart if
the beast wasn't there the ship has
enough on it to completely clear the
debt with sid
but if it was me yet i'd just take my
ship say i'm doing a mission
and then not go back who needs her now
echo says that they should have left
with rex
and clearly hunter wrestles back and
forth with this if you're against the
empire then the rebels is pretty much
the only possible path you can take
and who knows we may end with the group
going off to join them
on the ship they find several thermal
explosives and all the weapons they'd
need to fight off any potential
imperials
amongst these are proton torpedoes which
you may know as being what luke fired at
the death star to destroy it
if you've ever played a star wars game
then you've probably used them at some
point
and omega ends up going to the bridge
tech describes the wall in a very binary
way that just
involved an objective and it does sort
of show the limited perspective that the
grunts have
though the batch worse like deviants and
variations
they were still raised as soldiers that
wouldn't question orders
and it shows that omega has far more of
a scope when it comes to understanding
nuances
nowhere is this hammered home more than
when we go back to kamino
to learn that the reason the camera
owens wanted the batch brought in
was because of her we've long been
theorizing that because of her name
she is the end game of clone production
alpha means beginning
whereas omega means the end and it would
make sense that the cameron owens
ultimate goal would be to manufacture
force sensitive beings
as we predicted it was indeed them that
had been hiring the bounty hunters to
get her too
and it becomes clear she's far more
important than any other clone
crosshair arrives and we see that he's
still with the es team
that he's no doubt been training
crosshair is now a commander
and after realizing that they're being
jammed they start to stalk the area
because the bad batch have been part of
their ranks before they know the kind of
sweeping search they'll carry out
and they successfully evade the troopers
for some time after hacking their comms
however it's a trap and crosshair being
part of their ranks
knows the strategies that they'll take i
love how this
know thy enemy theme works on both sides
and it's clear that crosshair is off the
deep end when he says
[ __ ] them kids tech activates the
cannons to send the squad flying back
and we get our best action scene in the
series so far with omega using her bow
to show how far she's came
the group come face to face with the
flame trooper which i believe
was first shown in the force awakens
before they were retroactively put into
other properties like the mandalorian
and fallen order now what do you call it
when when the postman drops your order
hey
you're for you're falling order now the
batch sneaks through the ion engine but
crosshair preempts it and sits with his
sniper waiting for them to come
unfortunately tech restoring the power
means that the engine can be activated
but the batch managed to outsmart the
empire by using charges to break the
engine cylinder away
crosshair is badly injured during this
and it might be possible that he's taken
to the medical bay
which is where he discovers the thing
about his chip was true
knowing crosshair he might actually get
it deactivated at this point
and be amongst the empire's ranks when
he finally gets back his free will
this would mean that he's a mole inside
their organization and i think it would
be great if he came to this realization
in the next episode they clearly left
him badly injured for some reason
and there's a medical bay right next to
where he is so that just makes the most
sense to me when we're talking about
what could happen next time
the batch arrive at the ship to find
that all the clone troopers there have
been shot
and we see that this is being carried
out by one of my favorite star wars
characters
cad bane bane is a duros bounty hunter
who took on the mantle of the galaxy's
best
after the death of jango fett bane was
adept at fighting jedi
and he went toe-to-toe with some of the
best and held his own
his design was clearly influenced by
cowboys and i love the standoff that he
and hunter have
he's had a really long and rich history
throughout a lot of star wars properties
and he instantly changes the dynamics of
the show
now interestingly he does say that he
can't say who he's been hired by
so it looks like the show is trying to
make us think that others could indeed
be pulling the strings
actually quite like ryan aries theory
that boba fett is running a bounty
hunter network
and that the cameron owens gave the job
to him and then he passed it out to his
underlings
bubba or rather boba i grew up saying
boba yeah so i just naturally say
boba of course spent a lot of his
childhood with them growing up
so it does make sense that they'd have a
way to contact him he also of course was
allies with fennec shand
and if the pair worked together in the
past it would make sense why she was so
loyal to him
in the mandalorian anyway bane manages
to shoot first
and he then stuns omega though it seems
like hunter could be dead
his armor protects him and we get an
awesome first person scene of him being
rescued
and taken on board the ship as the
clones close in it's a gut-wrenching
empire strikes back-esque ending for the
episode
and it becomes clear that in the next
entry they'll have to track down cad and
stop him
before he reaches kamino or potentially
someone else
they too have the empire after them
meaning that the stakes have never been
higher
and i can't wait to see what happens
next time now as for my thoughts on how
the show is going
i really love how everything is fully
starting to ramp up
i very much felt that the first part of
the season was a bit slow
especially after that pilot but
everything is starting to fall in place
and instead of just seeing the batch
constantly on the run they're now having
to fight back
it was always gonna come to this and the
imperials are of course attempting to
strip the galaxy of as much free will as
possible so that they can control the
population
the bad batch are basically a
representation of people that have
broken free of conformity
and removing their chips was sort of the
last straw that meant they were no
longer going to be under the control of
the empire ever again
thus the only thing that the show could
do metaphorically was stamp them down
and i think there's been some great
conflict as we went towards this episode
it didn't disappoint and every entry
feels better than the last
i'm really really on board with it and
i'm looking forward to the next eight
weeks of covering this show
i was finding fun with it early on but
then sort of got to the point where
i didn't feel it was knocking out of the
park however now i think they've found
their groove and are delivering great
episode
after great episode i'd obviously love
to hear your thoughts on this episode
and the show as a whole
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for commenting on
the video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last
month's competition are on screen right
now so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
loki episode 2 which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul
and the force will be with you always
take care
peace